dangerously bad air still affects
millions of Americans due to wildfires
in Canada many cities suffered in heavy
smog yesterday including Washington
Philadelphia Baltimore and Nashville New
York City's air quality improved from
Once Wednesday's hazardous smoke
conditions that turn the sky orange but
it was still unhealthy to breathe let's
check the latest with meteorologist
Stephanie Abrams with our partners at
The Weather Channel good morning Steph
good morning there is relief on the way
but the next couple of days will still
have hazy skies and reduce the
visibility especially in the Great Lakes
and the Northeast today the worst air
quality is going to be into cities like
Detroit on into Pittsburgh and even down
into Raleigh and this type of pollution
is so harmful because the smoke
particles are tiny about 30 times
smaller than a strand of human hair so
they can get deep into your body and
cause serious health problems thankfully
this weekend into early next week a
system will come through that's going to
give us more of a southerly flow direct
the smoke away from the U.S the rain is
going to help clear out the air and it's
going to fall right over the Flames but
I'll tell you what we're going to need a
lot more to extinguish the hundreds of
fires that have already burned over 12
million Acres through Sunday the most
rain that we're going to see is about
one to two inches for more in-depth
coverage you can watch a weather channel
on cable or live on your favorite TV
streaming devices Vlad it's very
possible that this will be a long
duration event for both Canada and the
U.S
all right Stephanie Abrams for us thank
you Stephanie